so yeah as I was saying what we've got
here is one of the shirts that's
currently empty
there should be 6 000 Ducks filling This
Barn
but there isn't an animal in sight and
the feeders are empty I wouldn't say
we're Clinging On but it's it's had a
huge effect poultry farmer James has had
to Cull 20 000 of his Ducks just to keep
his processing Factory free of avian flu
the moment everybody in the industry is
just on tender hooks constantly as soon
as you get a new batch of birds in on
our other site you're apparently worried
every day you go and look at them duck
sneezes in a slightly different fashion
you're instantly thinking hang on a
minute is something wrong
the current avian flu outbreak is the
largest in UK history 3.1 million birds
have been curled so far Norfolk Suffolk
parts of Essex and the whole of the
southwest of England have been declared
Avian Influenza prevention zones due to
recent outbreaks and farmers are
concerned that if the spread continues
it could hit Christmas stock
it is a risk if bird flu for example
gets into into turkeys that could cause
holy Carnage you know that could cause
real supply chain issues you know in
their up to Christmas time
um you know the the realities of it are
quite severe influenza outbreaks have
been reported at more than 150 sites
across the UK but much of the
devastation has happened away from farms
there have been thousands of dead birds
washed up on beaches right across the UK
and while the poultry industry is braced
for a difficult season ahead it's the
wild bird population here that's already
been severely impacted
this wild bird Hospital in males all had
to Cull around 200 Birds after an
outbreak and conservationists say the
effect on the population could be felt
for years we've seen things declines of
between 55 and 80 percent of the
population of Great skewer in the UK and
we hold two-thirds of the world
population if that species gone straight
onto the Red List these birds are
long-lived you're talking about birds
that don't even start breeding for five
years and they may only have one chick
per year so it might take decades before
some of these populations recover
the government says avian flu poses a
low risk to the public and food safety
but poultry Farms are being asked to
increase biosecurity measures as this
outbreak continues to spread and
Whitehead Sky News in mousel Cornwall